yo what is up everybody this procedure
math Luigi here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel video now if you even
playing borderlands pre-sequel recently
you've been looking at some of the
explosive and corrosive and cryo barrels
a little bit more than usual you might
have noticed that there are these new
celebration barrels with little vault
hunter sign on them and when you shoot
them or to show them they explode with a
bunch of fireworks now this is in
celebration of the recent DLC they came
out i believe the handsome jack and
obligating a new class dlc and they come
with a little surprised if you destroy
enough of them you'll get lucky and
you'll get the contraband skyrocket
which is a unique grenade that can spawn
from only these bare these certain
celebration barrows I believe these are
the only way you can get them that's the
only way this grenade is gettable so you
can see it has a blast radius of 1,100
of use time of 1.6 and it says to not
use indoors it scales to your level so
in terms of damage so you don't have to
worry about damage is pretty strong but
it's not really you don't really get
this grenade for the strength you get it
for the fun now it says don't use indoor
is bz as you can see it just Rises
pretty close to straight up when you
throw it and it erupt in fireworks kind
of like the fireworks you saw in the
when you blew up the barrels so kind of
like a celebration so it's a pretty cool
grenade i am assuming the celebration
barrels are barrels i think that i think
they're called barrels right the
celebration barrels i think they coil
maybe they're gonna probably be going
away soon and i'm assuming that this
grenade will become if anything you'll
be able to get it from vendors I just
maybe craft it but it is a unique
grenade mod so I that might not be
possible all I also think it's always
incendiary but so i would suggest trying
to get an out I've gotten to and I'm say
I've get destroyed like 20 barrels or so
it's called the contraband skyrocket
you'll definitely notice it its scab
you'll definitely notice it if you
destroy the barrel it'll drop right next
to the barrel there will be a bunch of
fireworks but you'd have to worry about
that since the actual piece that drops
won't explode in too many of those
fireworks at least to my knowledge I've
experienced only two and they've both
been pretty good and you can see
throwing it up in the sky get some nice
little fireworks I think it is a pretty
cool nifty little thing that's about it
I do hope you get your own little
contraband skyrocket and have some fun
firework time in a celebration alright
guys hope you enjoyed this video if you
have make sure you keep looking around
my channel for more boring super sequel
stuff I do a lot of legendary guide so
be sure to check that out if you want to
get some legendary weapons and shields
and oz kits and grenade mods so I hope
you enjoyed peace out guys